[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing another perplexing what if
scenario that is what if peter pettigrew
had never betrayed lily and james potter
yes i'm talking about an alternate turn
of events where peter crew wasn't well a
rat figuratively speaking of course so
let's get into it when peter pettigrew
first came to hogwarts school of
witchcraft and wizardry it is said the
sorting hat took an entire five minutes
before deciding to place him in
gryffindor as we are to understand it
the hat was wavering between gryffindor
and slytherin showing very early on that
pettigrew had inclinations towards the
characteristics most seen in students of
the green and silver house that later
became obvious after sirius black
revealed peter to be a traitor and death
eater who had framed him for pettigrew's
crimes
faked his own death and lived as rat for
12 years peter was actually quite clever
ambitious and resourceful the main
characteristics of a slytherin pupil in
any case having been tortured into
gryffindor he very obviously lacked the
qualities of his fellow housemates he
was not particularly brave or courageous
and being that he was somewhat of an
underdog himself he never stood up for
the little guy after all peter was the
somewhat overlooked member of the
gryffindor gang the marauders a group of
friends that consisted of james potter
sirius black remus lupin and of course
peter pettigrew
the group bonded after discovering that
lupin was both a wizard and a werewolf
forming the marauders and going to great
lengths to all secretly become anime guy
that is james sirius and peter each
taught themselves how to turn into an
animal at will
peter's animagus form was that for
rodent which in the end turned out to be
quite fitting as he was quite the rat
double-crossing the order of the phoenix
and defecting to lord voldemort's
service as a spy but it makes me wonder
was it this very perception of peter
that he was rat like in nature not that
bright and referred to by his best mates
as worm tale that led to peter gru's
cowardice and betrayal of those he was
closest to what's more to be in a
position where your best mates were
idolized for their popularity james
potter was a quidditch star in his own
right and sirius was a handsome bad boy
type it may have been difficult to
maintain a sense of self-worth and
confidence which brings us to peter's
choice to become a death eater
it's said that petticrew double-crossed
the order of the phoenix and all of his
closest friends to follow voldemort for
one simple cowardly and selfish reason
he didn't believe there was any way to
beat the dark lord so wormtail decided
to join him before it was too late but
if peter's experience at hogwarts had
been just a little bit different would
he have succumbed to such cowardice
prematurely becoming a death eater and
giving up the potters to voldemort after
all much later on in the series
pettigrew shows hesitation in strangling
harry finally showing some semblance of
courage in resisting one of lord
voldemort's direct orders to kill harry
so he did have the ability to be brave
somewhere inside of him what if he'd
been able to tap into that
characteristic decades earlier
now in my opinion in order for petagree
to have demonstrated this type of
courage during voldemort's initial rise
to power perhaps it needed to start with
the simple things you know like his best
mates not referring to him as wormtail
as we've briefly touched on pettigrew
was clearly the lowest ranking member of
the marauders when it came to well
everything professor mcgonagall said he
wasn't a very good student he wasn't
idolized by his peers as james and
sirius were he wasn't particularly good
looking by any stretch of the
imagination
and to top it all off his so-called best
friends basically called him a rat i
know i know he was an animagus who could
transform into a rodent but surely there
was a more respectable name they could
have come up with other than worm tail
it just doesn't sound very flattering if
you ask me
of course i'm not saying that it's
james's fault peter betrayed him and his
wife obviously foolish childhood antics
like name calling can't be used to
justify a betrayal that leads to murder
but what i am saying is that perhaps if
pettigrew had been given a little bit
more respect especially amongst his very
best friends he could have become a much
more courageous and confident wizard
indeed so if peter had been treated
better by the marauders and had been
able to stand up for himself more often
he wouldn't have felt the need to go
running to sign up to be death eater at
the first sign of danger he wouldn't
have panicked instead he would have
stayed loyal to the order of the phoenix
to his friends and ultimately to the
potters in this hypothetical scenario
when james and lily decided to switch
their secret keeper from series to
pettigrew last minute he would have been
loyal to the end in my opinion though
peter's end would have come that much
sooner i know many of you don't like to
see the canon disrupted too greatly and
of course neither do i so in this what
if instance i'd like to think that even
if peter pettigrew had never gone over
to voldemort the dark lord still would
have had a spy on the inside of the
order of the phoenix who that would have
been for this particular instance
doesn't really matter but in any case he
would have had a witch or wizard on the
inside someone who he was able to
corrupt in ways that he was not able to
do to a more courageous version of peter
through this other non-wormtail rat or
sauce if you prefer voldemort would have
been able to determine that pettigrew
was indeed the potter's secret keeper
after all it seems likely that it would
have been one of the three wizards a
marauder of course meaning it would have
been sirius remus or peter
i really don't think that it would have
been all too difficult for voldemort to
narrow down the list from just three
wizards do you
and so determining that it was pettigrew
who held the location of the potter
family voldemort would have gone to
wormtail intent on uncovering what he
wanted to know
it's really not that far-fetched to
imagine that like he did so many times
throughout the harry potter series
voldemort would have successfully
tortured peter into telling him the
information he needed and then killed
him from there things could have played
out very similarly to the actual series
voldemort would have gone to godric's
hollow murdered lily and james attempted
to kill young harry only to fail
miserably be forced into hiding as he
regained his strength
sirius would have arrived at the
potter's house to find the devastating
scene and gone to look for peter upon
finding him dead as well it would have
looked like sirius had betrayed the
potters and killed pettigrew as a
double-crossing death eater and gone to
azkaban for crimes he didn't commit the
only difference here would be the peter
was never a death eater hadn't betrayed
it lily and james and had actually died
rather than staged his death well
there'd be no proof sirius did these
things you might be thinking well can
you honestly say there was much evidence
to convict sirius in the original
scenario i rather think not this change
in events would have then impacted the
weasley family although in no great way
in my opinion as you may recall in the
series patrick crew stays in his
animagus form for 12 years after faking
his death as a rat he came into the
ownership of percy weasley and was named
scabbers eventually he became ron's pet
rat to be perfectly honest though
scabba's never really contributed much
to ron's storyline
other than the fact that he was
eventually revealed to be the once
presumed dead peter pettigrew and so if
petaku had truly died the night of lord
voldemort's attack on the potters there
never would have been the pet scabbers
perhaps they would have found some other
normal rodent wandering around the
weasley property to take in instead
honestly from ron's perspective i don't
think it really would have made much of
a difference so all in all if pettigrew
had never betrayed lily and james potter
i think it would have meant that he had
been treated with a bit more compassion
during his time at hogwarts perhaps had
a different nickname among the marauders
and had grown up to be more courageous
wizard than he was in the actual series
and i truly believed that's all that
would have been different
hopefully not too disappointing of a
theory for you all what do you think
would much have changed if pettigrew
hadn't broken his oath as the potter's
secret keeper perhaps there are those of
you who believe that peter could have
kept voldemort from discovering the
potter's location and lily and james
would have lived let me know your
thoughts in the comments below and as
always if you enjoyed this video don't
forget to like it and subscribe to the
channel
until next time remember if you've made
a better rat than a human it's not much
to boast about peter
[Music]